what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I got a crazy chapter
to discuss this week we got one piece
Peak hype with the straw hat cp0 team up
against the seraphims not to mention the
return of Shanks in Epic fashion and
much more so make sure to stay tuned for
this Monumental chapter Channel parking
with it and smash that like button until
you see fireworks if you like these
weekly one piece reviews I want to keep
them coming make this the video you
joined the knock if you haven't already
by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and Updates this
chapter is called old friends because we
got surprise appearances from some fan
favorite characters but we'll save that
for later we got an awesome color spread
this week of the straw hats and as usual
great to see the Nami love but back to
the chapter itself we got Luffy and Zoro
being confronted by the mihawk seraphim
and the kuma seraphim last chapter Kaku
and Luchi were asking to be released so
that they could help fight the seraphims
as mentioned during the last chapter I
felt like they would release them
because they can't let them die in
handcuffs plus who doesn't like one of
those moments where old enemies have to
to team up to fight a new enemy Zoro is
now saying that yeah even if they fought
together he can't see a future where
they'd let the straw hats lock them up
again Kaku is the rational lying one
he's calm and collected and telling them
what they want to hear he says that's
not true if we can get through this
crisis we'll keep quiet and let you lock
us up again we then get a hilarious
moment of Luffy being naive and taking
everything at face value he simply says
alright that's fine by me while Zoro
freaks out at him saying Kaku is
obviously lying in the meantime seraphim
Miha goes in for an attack and we see
something very interesting indeed turns
out that just because mihawk doesn't
have a devil fruit Powers it doesn't
mean that s-hawk doesn't as they did
with seraphim jimbei they decided to
give asshawk a very fitting devil fruit
particularly the dice dice fruit the
power we've seen from Daz bones aka Mr
one he uses the power to turn his leg
into a blade for a second and sends a
slash attack flying at them with it Zoro
is shocked to see it and immediately
recognizes the power of the dice dice
fruit Kaku keeps trying to convince Zoro
to free them since as things are he
needs to protect them and he keeps
egging him on to just release them so he
doesn't have to worry about them and
they can help it's Punk number one AKA
Daft Punk who asks them point blank what
their mission is and I love how honest
Luchi is here he says Point Blank that
his goal is the elimination of the seven
Vega punks kaku's reaction is hilarious
as he says Mega Punk's literally
standing right in front of you Luchi I
love their Dynamic I really do for
antagonists especially it's very well
done and it's clear that Kaku and Zoro
are the two rational ones while Luffy
and Luchi are the two upfront ones Daft
Punk then says it also doesn't seem like
Stussy will get off the hook for
betraying them and Luchi hilariously
says yeah I'll never forgive her Goku
freaks out again asking him are you even
trying to save yourself I genuinely
really enjoyed the comedic aspect of
this back and forth Oda did a great job
with it I must say then Zoro hears
nami's scream he points out that the
four of them meaning the four seraphims
are on a rampage and he wonders how many
people they gotta protect now aside from
the seven Vega punks Luffy makes the
executive decision but rationalizes it
in the best and most hilarious way he
tells Daft Punk who he calls helmet to
give him the handcuffs Daft Punk does so
and tells them to protect the Stella
Luffy tells kakwan Lucci to their face
after we stop these four seraphims since
you can't beat me you won't go after my
friends or the Vega punks got it I think
it's the worst thing he could have said
to antagonize Luchi Zoro even tells him
not to provoke them like that and angry
Luchi says As You Wish because he wants
to kill Luffy first anyways so he'll
only turn on his friends after Luffy is
out of the picture a shock Zorro tells
Luffy to obviously not let Lucy join
after he said that but of course if he
does free them just in time for them to
dodge a giant ursus shock attack that
destroys the building itself so as you
guys know by now I wanted to see Zorro
go one on one against seraphim mihawk
desperately but here we have Luchi and
Luffy vs espair and Zorro and Kaku vs
s-hawk however they are not going all
out Luffy is even using gear 4 rather
than gear 5. now I'm not personally sure
if it's just to conserve energy because
it's not necessary or if Luffy just
doesn't have energy right now to
maintain gear 5 for long anyways Luffy
and Luchi launch a combined attack that
sends S Bear flying while Zoro and Kaku
do the same with s-hoc it definitely
looks like they have the upper hand for
now even if they aren't going all out
it'll be interesting to see what happens
and if we do switch to one on one at
some point especially considering there
are two other seraphims to deal with
then we jump to the research facility
and we finally figure out what happened
to the Stella Vega Punk their CP agents
inside of here as well some haven't had
a decent meal for two months it turns
out this is where all those appearing
agents ended up and of course chances
are that the one responsible is the one
messing things up from the inside they
were attacked by sea BEAST's weapons and
they thought it was because of vegapunk
but now that vegapunk is there in prison
with them and even beat up and bleeding
they apologize megapong says outright
that he had no idea something like this
was happening so that's one mystery
solved even if we don't know the bigger
mystery of who is responsible yet and
again this really feels like a one-piece
inspired Among Us game and I can't wait
to find out who the Imposter is and I'm
hoping it's a good scooby-doo-esque
shock someone we know of rather than
someone completely random we quickly get
a scene letting us know that Navy branch
G9 has set sail for Egghead and that
over 100 ships of all sizes are coming
as if this wasn't enough going on we
then jumped to a certain island in the
new world specifically to a bar at a
small Port it's interesting Oda
purposely recreates a familiar scene for
us it's a viking kid but he's exactly
like Luffy was when Shanks first visited
him he wants a pirate sport boiler it
shrinks again to take him along Shanks
like last time tells the kid that he
can't come and he calls him a hot-headed
brat and the kid is upset just as Luffy
was there's even another woman there
working at the bar to try to speak some
sense to the kid and of course the flirt
with Shanks the kid says he doesn't care
if he upset Shanks since he's going to
be the boss someday and then one of
Shanks his men interrupt him while he's
drinking telling him big boss someone
just attacked us he says it looks like
it's going to turn into a fight and if
you recall kid was at l-bath last time
we saw him so this is interesting stuff
Shanks wonders if it was good timing or
bad timing since they were just about to
depart he says that it looks like they
talked for too long he thought both of
his friends were dead so he couldn't
help it when he saw them there and the
reveal which we'll get to soon of who
these old friends are is big pun
intended but for now it's so nice seeing
shanks's crew here as well I feel like
this is the most attention Oda paid to
Shanks at his crew since the first
chapter Beckman says the enemy is surely
angry at them while Roo laughs and says
yeah they know who he holds a grudge
against the kid is excited that this
fight may start a war meanwhile Shanks
tells him to set sail while the crew
asks are we really doing this boss and
whenever someone says are we really
doing this boss it just Hypes up the
situation so much and the woman working
at the bar is clearly infatuated with
Shanks as he says he won't let the
island turn into a battlefield the funny
thing is the woman doesn't even think to
herself wow what a brave man or wow what
a Dependable man but rather just thinks
wow what a handsome man then it's
revealed who the old friends were when
Shanks asked Dory and bragi to lend a
hand of course they agree and as they
are revealed we also get the
clarification that this is in fact the
country of proud Warriors elbaf and
since elbaf and Shanks have been hyped
up for so long this is indeed big even
without the Epic Dory and bragi reveal I
hope we see some action here but Shanks
as usual wants to avoid fighting if
possible he tells him to give captain
get a message do you really want to
fight me now or will you leave your road
poneoglyphs behind and disappear Choose
Wisely end quote if kid answers right we
might get to see red hair versus red
hair and maybe even see a bit of what
Shanks is capable of in an actual fight
we then jumped a kid and it's looking
good for those of us who want to battle
he looks at his missing arm which is now
a Mecca arm and says back then we
couldn't even get a glimpse of big boss
red hair of course meaning Shanks they
were beaten to a pulp with no chance of
fighting back and can't even lost his
arm as pointed out killer tells him this
time he might not just lose an arm but
his life the stakes are high and the
situation is hype keep in mind the guy
just came from a victory over at yonko
granted it was with Law's help but still
he's probably feeling pretty confident
even though I don't see him holding a
candle to Shanks in all honesty he's
hot-headed though and he wants revenge
for his arm so it will still probably
happen we got La vs Blackbeard Luffy
versus the world government and now kid
versus Shanks this is so crazy right now
man and I love it we are so lucky to be
able to experience one piece right now
we then jump to Shanks and people
fangirling over him they even say they
wanted to pay tribute to him but he says
they don't have that kind of system
implying that Shanks doesn't collect
money in exchange for protecting his
territories it's awesome that people
still want to pay though Oda continues
to build up Shanks and his likability we
then get to see kids clearly worried
about determined face as he laughs in
front of his crew and says he'll only
lose his life if he loses the battle
right implying that he's not planning on
losing which is also High thing to say
like I want to give credit to kid Shanks
obviously no one can compare to him but
kid in his own right is a very cool
character and deserves respect Shanks in
contrast to the worried kid looks calm
and he's about to face the Supernova the
narrator even seems to spoil that a
fight will indeed happen as he says
fiery Warriors are about to clash so
much hype and as expected Oda gave us
some great stuff to hold us over since
there will be a break next week now if
you want to know exactly how strong
Shanks is and learn everything there is
to know about the character so far you
won't want to miss my Shanks as way
stronger than you think video link on
screen now and in the description it's
an hour-long video that will definitely
hype you up for the next chapter